scientists those crazy Cs and white
uniforms sitting in Labs all day they
are working on an obesity pill and what
they say this thing is going to do is
that it's going to turn bad fat into
good fat and if there's anything
Americans like it's an easy way to eat
all the that they want and maybe
not put on some fat although generally
Americans don't have a problem putting
on the fat as is anyway let's look at a
little more
info Harvard stem cell Institute has
identified two compounds that can turn
white or bad fat cells into Brown good
fat cells in the body when a person eats
too many calories and doesn't burn them
off they're stored as white fat cells
causing a person to pile on the pounds
the brown fat cells burn excess energy
reducing the number of white fat cells
okay every commercial that we see on TV
every day is for a pill that'll give you
a boner or it'll keep you awake or put
you to sleep or stop your legs from
shaking or make your legs shake or give
me something I haven't heard of the one
that makes your legs sh well I'm sure a
side I think a side effect to some of
the other ones make your leg shake some
will make you know they what else
potential the smoking ones make you want
to commit suicide then you can take
another pill to not want to commit
suicide anyway point is uh this is just
this is progression right now of course
we're going to do this with h with
weight and fat and all that yeah I mean
if there were something out there that
actually worked it'd be interesting to
see but I keep seeing different diet
pills different Miracle pills and none
of them ever do anything it's just like
go exercise and eat right like I don't
understand why that is like so hard for
people to like just adopt well and I see
this as being two different issues right
what we're talking about are kind of
weight loss things that are not FDA
approved that aren't medicine that are
sold in infomercials late at night this
has the potential to become a a real
pharmaceutical and I think it has the
potential to help people with gross
obesity with with severe obesity I mean
gross like big not gross like disgusting
um severe obesity that's causing um real
problems in their lives medically
generally speaking people who are that
obese are that obese not because they
can't stop eating but they're that obese
because they have other issues at play
and this could be uh a potential
treatment for them way down the road now
I think my problem with the way that
science is often reported is for example
right off the bat good fat and bad fat
white fat cells are good or are bad fat
Brown fat cells are good fat yeah well
depending on your perspective if you're
talking about whether or not I want to
be obese then yes Brown fat is better
fat is worse because white fat white fat
contributes more to obesity so when I
always say that avocado is a good fat or
butter good fat we're agreed on that
right that's a totally different keep
putting the coffee yes because those are
those are monounsaturated fats which are
not as bad for you hard thing to say too
but we're talking about fats that you
eat Tri different types of triglycerides
here we're talking about the cells in
your body that store fat the ose tissue
in your body a lot of animals have brown
fat that animals that h it keeps them
warm in the winter babies have brown fat
that's why they're so squishy but then
it falls Away really quickly um the
issue is that brown fat and and white
fat also contribute to other things so
they're already finding in these early
trials they haven't even really started
doing clinical trials on mice yet I
think they're in the early stages that
this uh pill could totally up your
immune system right so to that point I
want to get to what you said which is
just eat right and exercise I mean like
like she said there are some people that
this could really benefit but my concern
is that people are going to use this as
an alternative to a healthy lifestyle
and throw the rest of it out the window
and I mean later on in the article it
talks about how they think like part of
the reason for um being overweight is is
not because it's it's because of
serotonin levels so they want to get
something that targets serotonin and
then you won't have this problem anymore
but then if you continue reading and
it's like and part of the reason for
serotonin levels being so high is
because of all the fast food that they
eat it's like okay well if you could
just cut out the fast food then you
wouldn't have the serotonin problem you
wouldn't have the Obesity problem so
it's like they almost like and doesn't
exercise help your serotonin level yeah
and it's like you know exercising and
eating right makes you feel good you
know not even if it's not going to shut
a pound from your body you should still
do it and I'm just afraid that something
like this is just going to be another
excuse for most people you know it's
going to be like the next diet you know
fad people are just going to you know go
right so that that's the part that I
think is interesting yes obviously there
will be cases that if they can figure
this thing out it could really help the
extreme cases but we're we live in a
fast food nation where you know that
this pill 3 years from now is going to
be marketed the same way Viagra is
marketed or or whatever it is that
you're seeing on TV all the time and
then just the average person instead of
eating right and going to get the good
fat yeah and there will likely be
detrimental health effects that come
along with it because every the
commercial have three extra minutes of
yes every medication that you take it's
a risk benefit analysis there are people
who need meds and they have to deal with
the side effects that come along with
those meds because it's still more
worthwhile than them dealing with the
health problem that they would have
before they medicated that's the way it
works and and I think that one of the
bigger issues here is that in our
culture specifically we see the
correlation between being thin and being
healthy and we look at that like it's a
gold standard so instead of being
concerned about health we're concerned
about the way that we look yeah so like
you said good diet good exercise some
people aren't ever going to be that
skinny but they could be very very
healthy some people who are really
skinny have really terrible arteries
they have you know unhealthy hearts and
just because you take a pill that
converts good fat to bad fat that's not
going to do anything for the hardening
of your arteries because of all of the
cholesterol that you eat it's not going
to do anything for the other detrimental
health effects of eating poorly and not
working out so if you're that vain if
that's all you care about is the way
that you look maybe this pill is for you
but I would recommend trying to be
healthy first because you're going to
live a longer happier life you know
speaking of the vanity thing I watched a
movie a a couple nights ago was this
tiny movie with Scarlett Johansson came
out about a year ago I think it was
called in her skin am I right in her
skin under her skin uh and it was this
tiny little movie basically she plays
this alien that's wearing human skin uh
but she's naked in a lot of the movie
like a huge portion full frontal n and
she's probably eight pounds heavier than
what is always seen on uh in the movies
or television and I kept thinking that
she actually looked great like she
looked like a woman is to look not like
what we seal him like she looked
healthier to me and I was thinking I
don't know how nobody talked about that
I had even heard of the movie I randomly
came across it's a struggle you know I
I'll I'll admit like people who have
been watching me for the last 5 years
they probably know that when I all
through high school all through college
I was a very very very skinny tiny
little person I weighed like 95 to 100
pounds and only within the last few
years hitting 30 taking anti-depressants
quitting smoking all of these things
contribute and now I'm a I would
consider a healthier weight my BMI is
finally in the normal range I'm not not
like considered too skinny or
underweight but at the time on camera I
looked great and now on camera I
struggle because some days I go this is
me and I'm healthy and I feel good about
this and other days I can't help but
compare to the ingrained you know
sociological kind of expectation of like
am I fat like I look in the camera and I
go oh my God I'm fat I weigh 125 lbs
which is a normal healthy weight for a
woman every day I say once I get to 115
I'll be better I used to weigh 105 so I
weigh 20 lb more than I did most of my
life and as somebody who has a pretty
strong sense of self as somebody who's
on camera all the time and is kind of
like you I'm happy with this even I
still struggle and so can you imagine
what it's like for girls who weigh 135
for girls who weigh 140 who girl and and
they're still healthy that's the thing
and that's why I brought that up I can
promise you I'm healthier now as a
nonsmoker as somebody who eats a lot
better and who exercises more than I
ever was when I was just sucking down
cigarettes and caffeine every day but I
was super skinny on that note is Cara
obese should she use the Obesity pill
this is what we're going to do now avoid
reading the
YouTube yes oh my gosh I just want to
say but I just think people would focus
on health and not looks I mean I know
that you said this a lot of different
times but I get so much sometimes
for being too small and I I I have I see
it on your Instagram no eating problem
and I used to have that same problem
it's it's both ways and I just wish
people would stop focusing so much on
what people look like and just be like
are you healthy you are great because as
we now know me having lived both of it
nobody's going to be happy when
I'm 105 I'm too skinny when I'm 125 I'm
too fat somebody's always going to be
like you don't look exactly like I
expect somebody on the cover of a
magazine to look like well you know what
they don't look like that either phot
the porridge is too hot sometimes it's
too cold sometimes be who you are and be
healthy I think was the point that we
took away from
there